hey guys i am jess mcdonald it's the 60
second of May timbre and you're watching
games but news I'm just kidding it's me
the six and I'm sorry about yesterday
first that Microsoft's creative director
Ken lava said that their game lineup is
just as diverse as Sony's love said that
Microsoft does not slot filled life
seeking out games of a certain genre to
compete with other companies explaining
it's not a game we play I want to go and
find developers that want to make a game
that they think is perfect and then
we'll decide if that's something that's
interesting to us from a business
perspective and also from a portfolio
perspective but it's not gee I need a
fighting game I should make one of those
along the same vein he hit back at the
suggestion Microsoft forms Ford's the
developer turn 10 studios to compete
with gran turismo creator polyphony
digital next up Microsoft have set the
date for their e3 presentation which
they're calling Xbox game on it's going
to take place at nine thirty a.m.
pacific time on jun 9th and thus far
they're promising details on previously
announced games as well as unannounced
games coming in 2014 and beyond the
event will be streamed on xbox com xbox
live and on Windows Phones if you happen
to have yourself one of those xboxes
Major Nelson has also suggested that
there will be found centric events
before and after the live event let me
know in the comments what you want to
see Microsoft unveil this year the game
that we called a barely functional
disaster on our early access review has
been removed from the service by valve
for being well a barely functional
disaster gamers who spent their
hard-earned twenty dollars on earth year
2066 called it a scam and broken even
though games in early access and not
expected to be finished products talvez
stated that this one crossed a line
saying steam does require honesty from
developers in marketing of their games
customers who grabbed the game out of
what i can only assume is some sort of
masochism can get themselves a refund up
till the 19th of May
in news that'll make you realize you'll
never be able to single-handedly make
that big budget game of your dreams
Activision are throwing five hundred
million dollars at destiny the figure as
reported by Reuters have gone into
development and marketing for bungees
shared world shooter to present a
comparison analysts believe that GTA 5's
total budget was about 260 million to be
fair though GTA was a single release
while destiny will supposedly be
unfolding over the period of 10 years
analysts have said that activision will
need to sell 15 to 16 million copies of
destiny to break even and as a point of
comparison GTA 5 has sold 32.5 million
copies to date let me know whether you
reckon destiny will be able to hit a
home run in that commenting section for
comments down below those are all the
things that I have for you today but do
join me again tomorrow for a bunch more
news where there's a seventy percent
chance that I'll get the date right I'll
see you soon